et maintenant
j'accueille jean d'ormesson
jean d'ormesson mesdames et messieurs
bonsoir
bisous un biseau
tous ces disques vivre c'est un coup de
m
nous aussi on aime bien sûr mais bon ça
va bien heureux de pouvoir annoncer mon
corps mais bhl où ils sont
je n'ose même pas dire votre âge on peut
dire votre jeu aussi sans eric chez moi
j'ai peur d'être le grand père de tout
le monde mais vous êtes génial 80 ans
alors qu'est ce que je fais 4 et enfin
vous dit du bien de moi
catherine barma me demande que vous
changer de place voilà qui est là je la
place d'isabelle mergault qu'on m'a dit
de m'asseoir entre pierre et isabelle
elle est très dur de prendre la place
bien gens vous allez passer un bon été
très bon c est ce qu on supporte un vous
avez passé un été avec coo invitation
parce que je veux savoir si vous êtes
passés univers genre est-ce qu'on
supporte mieux les canicules quand on
est immortel haouidja le froid et le
chaud ça mais quand il n'y a pas de
problème ça va
alors voilà gens vous êtes de retour
parmi nous et j'en suis ravi parce que
ça vous fait un livre dit chez le
dernier
si vous finissez toujours par revenir
quand même pourquoi oui c'est honteux
cependant j ai reçue est claire s'il
était un peu à testament la wi lan et
puis je fais comme la castafiore je fais
mes adieux
et puis il revient vous it écrire c'est
difficile ne pas écrire c impossible
voilà en faisant voir green est
difficile parce qu'il est un peu si
belle formule très belle forme et vous
revenez en est ravi alors cette fois
vous publié chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle une fête en
larmes très beau les voir c'est ce qu'on
appelle un oxymore laurent et voilà tu
vas rhétorique la force tranquille je
vois cela fait gentiment larmes voilà
devient une nuit très clair voilà un
amour et de gaulle molle un oxymore demi
molle c'est une part de notre si
moralement alors le pitch du groupe k
âgé le faire le pitre c'est un écrivain
qui reçoit une jeune journaliste qui
vient à l'interviewer elle a 20 ans elle
sait rien c'est un peu bécassine faut
dire les choses et lui évidemment ici à
jour il sait tout puisque c'est vous
alors ce rendez vous qui devait durer
une heure ou deux va durer pas moins de
neuf heures pause déjeuner comprise et
le vieil écrivain qu'elle vient
interviewer va lui raconter sa vie c'est
à dire votre vie romancée votre vie
rêvée dans l'esprit de ce que aragon
appelé le mentir vrai on sait jamais si
c'est c'est assez énervante c'est un peu
pointe pour brouiller les pistes
cette force ou brunel pis vous êtes fort
on sait pas on ne sait pas mais je ne
sais plus je raconte ma vie mais je
l'inventé
là il se trouve que l'écrivain aux
questions vous a connu la grand mère de
la jeune fille alors là c'est parti vous
parlez de votre enfance de votre famille
du château il ya des choses
extraordinaires
pourtant vous avez parlé de ce château
un oui je me parlait beaucoup aux
plaisirs de dieu ça a commencé avec ça
mais bon alors vous dites nous étions
réactionnaire la vie était comme elle
était dans les siècles passés
et l'avenir nous intéressait peu c'est
une vie de lenteur plus tourné
finalement effectivement vers le passé
que vers l'avenir iec surtout que rien
ne change ouais ouais voilà et moi ce
que j'ai aimé c'est que les choses
changent
ouais c'est vrai alors vous dit une
chose c'est qu'à l'époque vous dites on
était chrétien ont été intimement
persuadé que tous les hommes étaient
frères mais de là à croire qu'ils
étaient égaux c'était quand même autre
chose quoi hein
il y avait un ordre des choses des
choses et nous étions au sommet voilà
voilà
hop vous racontez vos amours une léa et
une marie t elle je vais à l'amérique je
suis professeur la veille et je tombe
sur une jeune juive qui sort du ghetto
de varsovie est alors né a vécu là
dedans a échappé à la shoah est arrivé
en amérique à la suite d' aventure
extraordinaire et je tombe amoureux
d'elle et malheureusement je rencontre
une autre jeune femme marie et je
découvre peu à peu que mari son frère
était non seulement collabos non
seulement vichyste mais a servi dans
l'armée allemande
sous le lit forme allemand et a été
fusillé à la libération
alors vont vous voyez à à travers ma vie
a raconté le 20e scellera la cep
épouvantable est à 7 du pouvant table
déchaîné 6 sinistre j'ai calculé que il
devait y avoir dans le livre dit vas y
avoir entre 100 et 200 millions de morts
par violents eh bien je compte qu'un à
plutôt 300 millions avec la shoah et
quote-part centration les goulags la
chine le soudan le polpot le maintenant
un chalumeau
c'est le siècle des idéologies genre
bien sûr on va vous raconter vos voyages
vous racontez vos premiers livres au
plaisir de dieu qui n'avait plus de
modestie etc ce qui m'a toujours il vous
dit d'ailleurs effectivement vous avez
pas de succès un jour etc et les mêmes
un bouquin qui s'appelle au revoir et
merci
puis vous savez ce que c'est ouais on
retombe et j'ai fait un bouquin sur un
empire imaginaire dont j'étudiais d'
c'était une espèce de canulars
universitaire qui était la joie de
lambert et et ça faisait huit cents
pages je lui ai apporté chez grasset qui
a été épouvanté que pour vous publiez
j'ai apporté chez gallimard et il a fait
ça sans me voilà voilà comment ça se
passe voilà alors votre bouquin vous
vous dites c'est un roman mais quand
votre intervieweuse page 235 vous
demande ce que vous êtes en train
d'écrire vous dites une espèce de machin
oui c'est un truc oui parce que il est
vrai que quand je commence le livre je
suis d'ici dans la conversation
l'intervieweuse mais dans la réalité je
me disais je ne vais plus écrire des
livres
et puis au fur et à mesure que je parle
avec elle eh ben mon livre est en train
de se faire et quand le quand la
conversation du fini évalue livre figure
alors vous voyez de l'interview dans ce
livre dit que pour vous l'interview et
un est un supplice parce que vous
refusez de parler de votre vie privée
bridge je parle souvent de moi même mais
jamais de ma vie privée oui c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai qu'on sait pas en fait
moi je le sais parce que je vous connais
pas ce que vous savez tout mais j'en
parle très peu
j'ai beaucoup aimé michel vaujour les
silences
je trouvais ça épatant en parler de
l'amour gens très bien de mieux en mieux
mais je trouve que vous êtes vraiment à
chaque fois alors là pour le coup c'est
pas la même chanson pour encore après
femme sait plus très bien pour vite
l'amour c'est ce qu'on a trouvé de mieux
pour rendre la vie supportable
bien sûr de quoi est-ce qu'on s'occupe
d'autre de quoi est ce qu'on se dit très
séduisant soit mais il est allé à
convaincre le bienvenu il a doublé en
plus non mais ça je m'en fous
8la des phrases fortes dit au sujet de
la vieillesse
vieillir ses seuls moyens de paiement
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est ce que
j'ai fait alors vous parlez de la mort
vous dites la vie n'est belle que parce
que nous mourrons ici ça insupportable
mort il a dit des conneries aussi les
votants et il est mortel y'a qu'un truc
dans votre boucard moi qui m'a fait rire
c'est vraiment j'adore ce bouquin mais
quand vous dites ces films toi interview
donc il dit à la jeune fille qui
l'interviewent qui vient d'un magazine
comme ça et il lui dit je vous ennuie
avec toutes mes histoires et tout en non
messieurs d'ormesson au nom vous
m'ennuyer pas vous êtes tellement
intéressant ça s'appelle enfin alors
shing fort complet vrai c'est un peu
pareil c'est lui qui fait les questions
et les réponses
alors voilà alors il ya deux types de
réactions par rapport au bouquin vous
avez vu il ya ceux qui disent y'en a
marre on n'en peut plus genre beigbeder
dans voici qui dit c'est la énième
compile de d'ormesson
c'est vrai c'est un peu comme comme dave
c'est à dire que oui c'est fort vanina
il le dit pamela vanina de d'ormesson
c'est chateaubriand quoi c'est à dire
que l'on peut plus il ya télérama aussi
qui dit jean d'ormesson ressasse ses
poncifs sur venise sur la chute du mur
de berlin c'est une paresseuse
dissertation de causeur monde donc ça
c'est fait c'est fait c'était serré mais
et puis on en parlera plus en papa pitt
gaz ja ja eysines dans l'ope s'ils
rentrent aux veines dans le point il ya
le nourricier alors là il vous trouve
épatant délicieux que les gens ne se
lasse pas de vous finalement qu'est-ce
qui vous rend tellement sympathique ses
beaux yeux c'est quoi
et complètement séduisant il est jamais
que sortant vous il est il est
intelligent il à liffré ille et il est
ravissant cet homme est ravissant
totalement de nalcor de la dore voilà on
est avec lui moi demain il me demande en
mariage et bien peu de gens qui auraient
pu s'arrêter moi j'étais témoin de
jéhovah je veux bien faire